há algumas semanas ao terminar uma aula
de parada cardíaca foi abordado por dois
alunos
todo mundo sai da sala
minhas coisas e michel além de abordar
para fazer um convite da cia que quero
muito bem a história com experiência que
deixa uma mensagem a platéia na horta na
hora em algumas semanas tentando
encontrar o técnico novamente amanhã
plantão ele gosta que transporta para
região com urgência o final do ano mas
ninguém aqui na faca
os cursos do clube semana ela falar
sobre aquela lembrança primeira o fato a
primeira história primeira vivência em
meio ao menos naquele final de tarde
quando os meus alunos
o nome já entrega o cacho nós roberto
lunelli
nem caixa aqui vou me referir a partir
de agora como jorge anjinho o perigo
talvez um cara mais inteligente mais
preparado mais estudado é estudioso em
carros de som o ministro
o piloto da força aérea no interior de
são paulo não conseguiu estudando isso
de maneira brilhante os três são
brilhantes mais jovem chamava atenção
violão tocava guitarra muito jóia era
atleta o mais saudável em todos os
negócios o relatório a fish fazia
maratona aquática de uma vivência e
experiência do meu tio nas forças
armadas
ele foi meu marido se realizou em
tecnologia evita colisão de um avião num
computador
ilumine dizia que o projeto último
projeto que ele estava envolvido foi
lançado o espaço ao mês após o primeiro
satélite com tecnologia 100% brasileira
lançado na guiana
mas foi produzido em são paulo
revira mora em mim os fatos é virar as
vivências mas algumas coisas não têm
explicação
numa bela sexta-feira de 2014
estava eu consigo um helicóptero
jorge precisa de um jovem está mal
são paulo 15 e copa são paulo decidiu
manter os assuntos
nesse meio tempo fique sabendo que
estava acontecendo com jovens mesmo aos
41 anos metade saudável ao meio dia ao
[Música]
conseguir ou não de cirurgia de
emergência no desespero
nos últimos dias duas primas médicos
também uma pediatra e um radiologista
não são mamede existe em tudo aqui
mulher e criança o avião possa até hoje
o pior a pior imagem de um acidente
vascular cerebral
eu falei até chegar o momento de
[Música]
trabalhar de trabalho no coração o
sangue do cérebro 9
[Música]
o pior aconteceu
recebi mas o guardião não conseguia mais
ligar um tecido novo em que morre um
pouco tempo não recebe só deu certo
precisamos tomar uma decisão
extremamente surpreendeu o time fez
história para vocês hoje
[Música]
na época o coração deles e nós
precisamos de autorização
digão de forma jorge não é até hoje um
ano disseram se for comprovada
só vamos falar não sei se o nokia
desgraçado esse sentimento de querer dó
ajudar outras pessoas de forma
absolutamente à vontade mas foi um
desejo e uma no hospital assinar com as
coisas do brasil jorge há absolutamente
irreversível
um só fundamento ou seguir o desejo ao
mesmo jovem mas com certeza da família
em nossa história
numa manhã de quinta feira a domingo
na manhã de quinta feira jorge e como é
que a gente ia transportar o jorge para
brasília num avião da força área no
momento
socorristas do samu já atende a inúmeras
vítimas principalmente não trabalhava em
são paulo o motoqueiro jovens ou
acidentes graves problemas grandes
gravíssimo que a gente aprende todos os
esforços na manutenção da vida daquele
shopping às vezes conseguia salvar
aquele cidadão mas os órgãos desde a
gente sabia que meu salvar muitos dos
jovens mudou e os jogos que foram
retirados pela equipe de transplantes na
cidade de campinas que veio aos 10
dois helicópteros pousaram na cidade os
jogos deles foram rapidamente
transportados para serem transplantados
como a gente tem no brasil algumas
dezenas de milhares de pessoas em fila
esperando of milhares de pessoas fazendo
hemodiálise na espera de um modo de um
parente em nota ao vivo mas muitas vezes
precisa vídeo do ator
e esse fato cirúrgico só vai se
concretizar o ato de gustavo para lá
além do em 30% nos últimos dois anos por
seus planos
a nossa região oeste é a região que mais
tantos quanto o que mais gera doadores
pega mais geradores para o estado
nós somos hoje o maior gerador do douro
sul do estado
são campanhas educativas campanhas
explicativas para de muita ansiedade mas
despertar nas pessoas o interesse vou
lutar pela nossa muito ainda precisa ser
feito mas somente com este ato de amor
ainda inúmeras pessoas que precisam
muito obrigado
o tema que tinha escolhido no final das
contas ela me disse você vai conseguir
falar até o final daquela semana e souza
estava com o jovem foi extremamente
dolorido
[Aplausos]